hi in this video we'll talk about
vitamin b6 now vitamin b6 comes in three
flavors I mean they're combinely known
as vitamin b6 they are pyridoxine pile
Doxil or paradox I mean all are
basically pyrimidine derivatives so in
this video we would learn about them and
learn about the chemistry so pyridoxine
pyridoxine or pyridoxine
all are different variants from which in
an enzymatic way the active coenzyme is
produced which is paradoxical 5
phosphate I mean you can imagine it as
an active form which would be used as an
coenzyme for several important metabolic
enzymes we which we would be learning in
this video now from pyridoxine from
Paradoxal and from pyridoxine the first
step is to phosphorylate these compounds
using PI rock salt kinase after
phosphorylation most of the cases using
the help of enzyme PNP oxidase this
compounds are oxidized to PI log cell 5
phosphate you know first of all this
hydroxyl 5 phosphate could be an enzyme
for several
enzymatic reaction it has been reported
more than 140 enzymatic reaction used by
also 5 phosphate as its coenzyme now
these vitamin b6 could be obtained from
fish leafy vegetables legumes cereals
meat egg and even from seeds which
contains a lot of oil like sunflower
seeds or olive oil seeds like that
vitamin b6 or pairi oxalá 5 phosphate is
super important in context of amino acid
metabolism especially the enzymes which
are important for transamination
deamination requires by rock cell 5
phosphate or PRP as a coenzyme
especially transaminase use PRP as its
coenzyme now when in transamination when
substrate amino acid is getting
converted to a keto acid at the
dime hydroxyl phosphate gets converted
to pyridoxine phosphate so you can
understand the catalysis of this
reaction requires PLP not only that
inside of our blood we know there is the
active molecule is hemoglobin and
hemoglobin has him moieties which are
oxygen carriers now what happens is this
heme synthesis the key enzyme which is
important for him synthesis which is
known as Delta aminolevulinic acid
synthase or this enzyme converts
succinylcholine glycine into Delta amino
level unique acid the first and foremost
step off him synthesis
this requires PLP as its coenzyme so we
can understand if vitamin b6 is not
there and PRP is not there this
particular Allisyn tests our Delta
aminolevulinic acid synthesis is
non-functional now with the deficiency
of this particular enzyme him is not
produced and the result it might lead to
an anemic state not only that vitamin b6
deficiency always accompanies vitamin b3
deficiency because we know vitamin b3 or
niacin is actually produced from
tryptophan via several enzymatic step
now at the last step kinda ruining is
getting converted to Nia seen with the
help of Chi Nehru Nene's now this kinda
ruining means is an enzyme which
requires PLP as its coenzyme so without
pay this the production or the
biosynthesis of niacin is also hampered
now you can clearly understand if pius a
deficiency of p6 and p3 are correlated
both the deficiency can leads to
pellagra which accompanies with the dry
and scaly skin and inflammation
especially or rashes and blemishes
near the facial region other than this
thing vitamin b6 deficiency often leads
to problem in glycogenolysis we know in
glycogenolysis glycogen phosphorylase is
super important
now this glycogen phosphorylase use by
rock cell 5 phosphate as an cohen time
and it takes active part in the
catalysis process and that's why in
glycogenolysis vitamin b6 is so
important and that's how it is important
in context of glucose metabolism not
only that several important
neurotransmitters such as dopamine or
adrenaline adrenaline surgery in all
these things bio synthesis requires
enzymes and most of these enzymes
invisible synthetic pathway use PRP as a
coenzyme and you can clearly understand
with the deficiency of vitamin b6 these
enzymes are not functional or less
functional which might lead to an
imbalance of this neurotransmitter in
the synapses ultimately the result is
peripheral new varieties not only that
the daily requirement of vitamin b6 is 1
to 2 mg but during lactation or
pregnancy it is increased to 2.5 mg per
day now too much vitamin b6 is also a
problem we have already seen that
vitamin b6 deficiency has many
consequences but too much vitamin b6
could lead toxicity it might lead to
numbness Norv damage muscle pain muscle
atrophy and many other features so
that's why AB fine balancing of vitamin
b6 in the body is super important for
healthy physiology so I hope this video
was informative and it was useful if you
like this video if it comes up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
to let me know in the comment section
that how you like my videos and what
improvements you need in these videos
thank you